actually chess boxing i've been been to  something eventually seen it it's it's  really good fun yeah what is it like in  an arena as a as a spectator  it's great it's great i mean it is it's  like i mean i think they should do this  maybe with chess sometimes you know get  the players in like it's a darts match  here comes it comes big  big eddie or whatever but like  attack the shack attack comes in  had the crowd sharing but yeah no chess  books and it's a crazy sport and  it's really good fun to go and watch  yeah you get a chance  and it's a little bit of it in england  right it happens a lot in england  and uh we have a result jordan has  resigned we will be seeing tie breaks  hey jordan van furies he resigns and uh  shakira and mommy are makes a comeback  to tie the match so in 15 minutes these  two will start  let's tie breaks jordan just putting his  hoodie on  super just  disappointed